foreign
commentary for Dominion's Jurassic world
it's minions two day folks let me know
two of three of us forgot to dress up
however Danielle is celebrating in true
gentle lady minion style
um it's true I look like I'm about to
pledge for like a sorority on a black
campus yeah it's pretty great yeah thank
you I totally forgot that we had yeah I
also forgot they just sent out the email
yeah purely yeah I I had a suit at home
picked out ready to go just did not
think of it at all regardless we are
three adults talking about the second
Minions movie thank you for joining us
uh we'll be watching The Honest Trailer
together we will uh show you some
outtakes answer your comments and
questions in the chat and then tease you
with next week's honest trailer a more
grown mature film for grown mature
audience thanks for the disturbing the
sterning discerning
uh we're an adult words don't matter uh
the neither did the minions and yet uh
I got nothing I got nothing to say I
don't have anything it's like it's a
dumb funny stupid movie about them
hitting each other and falling a lot of
farts a lot of farts a lot
um I feel like sometimes we watch stuff
and I'm like I don't get the appeal like
this is not for me but I don't get it
it's for somebody else and I don't
understand this one it's not for me but
but I I get it kids like you know
getting knocked around falling down it's
very slap sticky it's it's broad Looney
Tunes level cartoon comedy and like all
right sure yes there's room for that why
not they certainly overstay their
welcome I think that the minions were a
nice spice to add to Despicable Me and
then over time they have just really
been like like there's a reason
um you know uh Adult Swim shows are like
12 minutes long there's just like only
so much you can take of a certain kind
of humor before it gets yeah it became
like the Urkel where it's like yeah
there's no oops all Urkel uh well I
guess Family Matters did come Yeah Yeah
final two seasons of Family Matters it's
basically oops do you see that a
crossover where uh with him and um step
by step where he like builds a jet pack
just crashes into their backyard he's
like urkles here baby it's Circle time
Family Matters originally was a spin-off
of perfect strangers as well so there's
a lot of tgifs that would be an
interesting connected Universe to uh the
TGIF verse yeah yeah there's a lot of
interconnection we also uh he visited
full house once and he maybe because
because uh I think DJ was sad and he had
to be like hey people think I'm weird
but I'm cool right and she's like yeah
Urkel you're cool or something I want to
say just the 10 of us maybe got in on
this too but I can't be the key to all
of this I feel like that all the tgaf
shows there was a little bit of back and
forth there and this is how much we care
about me yeah the minions
what else is there to talk about the
yeah
I was gonna say I feel like the first
thing because I went back and watched
the I have not seen the first minions
when we wrote this I went back the first
one as well that one it definitely feels
like wow this is a lot of just minions
this minions 2 or minions colon the rise
of grew uh I feel like they did a better
job of like oh we got to bring some
human characters into this so it's not
just wall-to-wall minions minions and I
felt like they it was better because of
it like that we spend a little time with
Gru and wild Knuckles and the vicious
six and it's like it's nice to take a
few minutes free of minions yeah like
because I can't once they all start
talking to each other I'm like my brain
just becomes a sieve like it all just
goes I mean you do re-enter the the
headspace of a toddler where that's what
all language sounds like
um and yeah wait your random European
words yes
yeah we're just look we're not the we're
not the target audience of this film and
even I as the as a parent of a young
child also missed out because I feel
like people aren't getting into the
minions now this is usually this is like
people as evidenced by The Gentle
minions Trend this is people's like
finale their goodbye they're bar
mitzvahs they they grow they've seen
this final Minions movie and now they're
off this is not the final Intuit movie
Despicable Me 4 is in production right
so I don't know where I don't know where
you're getting this from there's a
minions generation the minions will
return folks the first people who saw
Despicable Me are now they have their
driver's license they're going to
college they grew up with just just as
we had a previous generation that grew
up with the Shreks this generation has
grown up with domination right me Shrek
a bunch of uh what are we Millennials
Jen Jen whatever
uh I'm Millennial yeah uh the whole
scope
from the studio that made you mute your
and on Facebook comes one of the most
insanely idiotic things that you will
ever see at no point in this rambling
incoherent film will it come even close
to anything that could be considered a
rational thought everyone in the theater
will be Dumber for having seen it so I
awarded all the points and made God make
millions of us all
minions the rise of
grues uh that's reference to Billy
Madison yeah another topical which
itself itself was mocked as like the
dumbest lowest form of Comedy when it
came out and now I feel like if you went
back and watched Billy Madison it's like
oh you know it's fine it's great it
holds up perfectly there you go Circle
of Life continues
the minions are free to continue their
loony Reign of Terror
with returning favorites like Stuart
he's Stuart Kevin he's a next and the
other one that one has braces cute in
this wacky franchise all right all right
Mr minion expert why don't you give me
three words to describe Kevin Okay Kevin
he's he's the tallest he's their leader
I thought Bob was the tallest no Bob's
the shortest Kevin's the tallest he's
the leader wrong in the trailer Stuart
no I corrected you you got it wrong
originally and then I wrote an email
back that was like you know you've mixed
up Bob and Captain uh Kevin's the
tallest he's he's their leader he's very
he's a little arrogant Stewart in the
first Minions movie loves music but then
they totally dropped that one in the
second one he's got one eye uh and he's
like he's kind of like a an
individualist he likes to kind of break
off it like I'm gonna do things on my
own and then Bob is like naive and
innocent and he's the smallest one and
then Otto is Danielle yeah well the big
one what were your thoughts on new
newcomer Auto which one was Otto here's
the big one with Grace oh he's the he's
the kind of stupid one that falls in
love with a rock yes yeah they're all
different they're all the stuff they're
all the stupid ones but he is the one
who falls in love with the rock all
right
all right uh they're all minions folks
what can I say keep playing they're only
four those are the only four menus we
get to know there's a whole lot of other
Minions that are just like they have
names but they're just in the background
yeah
and all the heroes are their adorable
little slaves don't worry they like it
see it's in their nature to work on pay
for Life unions are the real super
villain right Bob remember the last
Minions movie neither does this Minions
movie because they forgot the minions
already know grew and that is how the
minions found their new boss when you
guys responded to my help wanted them
for God grew already knows Dr nefario if
you ever get famous remember guy be your
first Gadget forgot that 11 year olds
tend to look different eight years later
and you know what why do I even bother
men you like banana Minify playing go
boom so pause yeah we've lost the game
by even
even trying I got irrationally upset
about that after having just watched the
first one being like wait wait we're
retconning but if us such casual minion
fans notice these glaring disparities
film ruined uh no yeah but I did I was
surprised because it's the same creative
team right the guy the same guy I don't
know if it's the same writers but peer
coven the voice of the minions has been
on board for the whole time and I think
the director is the same guy yeah that
they wouldn't
um because they just seemed like
unforced errors because they did all
that stuff yeah you could just have
watched like the first movie before you
write the second but there's you know a
new a new dummy born every minute it's
weird that they go to the trouble to
specify something unfunny like a wanted
ad like if they had a funny idea for how
Gru was going to re-meet the medians I'd
be like okay but they had a funny new
idea okay but that was what they thought
they're funny though like I put an ad in
the paper and you responded like well
I'm laughing already hilarious
go on tell me more about the classifieds
about yeah like that's such a relatable
thing that kids today or know all about
I just have like a real like hello
darkness Smiles in my head at this point
continue I don't even hate this that
much I know but like the fact that we're
analyzing minions yeah that's our job
baby
not every week
yeah that's right all right keep it
sometimes it's Morpheus
watch Gru become the house boy of an old
San Francisco leather daddy in his Harem
Erb henchman they're taking the fight to
the vicious six a diabolical gang of 70s
movie tropes led by the most necroick
sassy character in animation history and
they literally had Beyonce play Nala
she's flanked by an ageless Jean-Claude
Van Damme it's time for the Next
Generation
sir you are 60 and a nun who proves that
yes Catholicism exists in the minion
verse and he is on the side of evil
[Music]
pause together I did laugh when that
happened I chuckled they all they all
Escape up the ropes and then she just
levitates uh the power of Christ it's
crazy that everybody from The Vicious
six is being voiced by a legitimate
insanely film star and they all get one
line of dialogue if that like that's
Lucy Lawless is that as that none
insanely famous
people know I will stand up for Xena if
you're gonna cast Dolph Lundgren
you know like like why get names if
you're gonna just have them grunt for
the home she's not on Cameo okay she she
to me is uh is famous at that point yeah
I she's she's Xena come on if I can name
this celebrity and you can name their
character like that they're famous
they're famous but we also I mean like I
I'm pretty sure now that I think about
it because I pointed out there's other
fun kind of cameos for me not for
children they won't care
um rizza's in this yeah and it is
actually great and one of the invokes
from invoke is in this wait what yeah
done something can't remember her last
name
um but yeah she is she plays like one of
the Bacon points
yeah she plays one of the bank employees
and I'm pretty sure she gets more lines
of dialogue than well surely Trejo gets
one I think literally one line he just
he's there to Grunt and then the other
weird thing I I don't know if this made
it in the trailer I don't think so uh
two of The Vicious six are are clearly
like movie archetypes like uh the the
leader is like a Foxy Brown Cleopatra
Jones black exploitation and then Dolph
Lundgren's character is exactly
rollerball like that costume he's
wearing is the rollerball outfit but
then the others are just made up like
like a lobster guy
Claude like wait I like what I
came on
there's so many famous 70s movies and
tropes and stuff you could play with
yeah that's the things the selective
well it comes up later but the the fact
that these this is the second minions
film that's really made its bones in the
late 60s 70s right era which is the age
of children's grandparents right now
right like older Grandparents were
getting those references it's strange
like yeah like like a Frampton Comes
Alive references old for parents we know
that because my dad was like right
that's what I mean like yeah it's like
those are my parents references and like
my kid you know yeah like I'm the age of
a college-aged kid parents
all right keep going
to steal the ending from Kung Fu Panda
but let's be honest this is a better
Sinister Six movie than whatever Sony is
cooking up
if you want to watch Dave Correll with a
big nose and a funny voice abuse some
under legs check out Fox catcher
ungrateful ape
Adams zone out for 90 minutes then it's
group time baby because this one is full
of slapstick comedy
four jokes
laughs
and silly nonsense gibberish-like
Spanish
it's still weighed down by a constant
stream of Boomer references too old for
even today's parents
[Music]
about Don Rickles he's the guy from Toy
Story ages three and up I'm not supposed
to be babysitting princess drool so drop
your expectations lower than this little
dude's pants and trying to just kind of
go limp mentally for a car too that's
not exactly breaking new ground but it's
guaranteed to entertain little kids
adults stunning for their GED and gen Z
is coping with the eminent end of their
childhood Welcome to the Real World kids
where everyone is somebody's minion so
pause uh Danielle you're dressed up for
this um can you unpack the the gentle
minions meme for us I don't know where
that came from I'll be on and I'm too
internet okay like this is a meme that's
so internet that it's like two internet
for me Ryan oh I don't know he doesn't
know he doesn't know okay Ryan doesn't
know wow once you get into like high
school Trends it's always like this you
know more like nobody over the age of 22
should understand where it came from
yeah no like we're not supposed to know
yeah no no no if I could explain like
exactly what 17 year old made this yeah
red flag right right right yeah I mean
and just broadly
it's funny it's funny to put on a suit
and go see the minions too and then two
like you can post about it which seems
to be the other requirement right now
definitely it was a big like oh this
will be a funny video I did I will say I
appreciate a lot of uh like teen Trends
or like it part of it is annoying people
or making a spectacle out of yourself
and I liked that this one was they're
dressing up but they're being very
respectful you know like it wasn't about
disrupting the minion screening it was
about like sitting quietly in it
I appreciate it like you feel like even
if you were there when this was going on
it wouldn't have like ruined your
experience of watching minions Rising
which is weird because it did irritate
some people and I'm like guys like four
years ago these kids were eating
detergent yeah this is the nicest
possible yeah
yeah I'm mad at him yeah
um I think it is like a whether it's
conscious or not it's like a uh end of
the childhood rite of passage like I
five years ago I was in Middle School
and before that I was even watching
minions when I was a little kid and now
like look how far we've come and I'm a
grown man now yeah I'm going to then
like sit patiently and watch uh minions
too and then when I emerge I will be
when I grew up I put away minion things
I'm hearing that vitamin C like song you
always hear at graduation yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
my prank you can't always get what you
want that's gonna be with me forever I
do have to say that that beginning of
them doing the Bond theme in in yeah I
was like okay that's pretty funny
because it reminds me there's something
that's going around right now because
um a bunch of people have just
recognized that the Black Eyed Peas song
Let's Get It Started used to have a
different name oh I will not say but
there's the r word that we don't say
anymore used to be that oh sheep
she really hit it but so there is a
version of that song that is also in
simlish and so that's what that reminded
me of
that might be the most early 2000s or
whatever year that came out yeah wow it
was from that there it was from the uh
the simless uh
[Music]
which is why they used the black guy of
course this is the Black Eyed Peas go to
any inner city in America they're bump
in the Black Eyed Peas yeah they love
Fergie
okay uh number one Urban continue
playing the trailer
sorry
I grew Simpsons tumors Raiders of the
Lost are good Cleopatra clones yo mama
jokes Bad Boy Records John Claude Van
Damme okay that's a good one Cena
Warrior priorist I must scared you
machete grunts in a booth for an hour
and young Sheldon
World dominions
it's not winning any Oscars but this is
easily the second best Michelle yo and a
googly-eyed rock movie of 2022.
it's one of those strange coincidence
yeah there's no way they could have
planned that out yeah it's like the gum
thing where it's like why is that
suddenly like all of these action movies
revolve around gum a guy uh
charismatically chewing gum yeah
um thank you all for watching uh like
And subscribe hit the Bell uh and catch
other things
um on other places like the honest theme
song on uh screen jockeys that still
exists for drastic Jurassic world
Dominion not for the minions uh no um
check out the uh the herbs uh simlish
cover it started yeah and today
[Laughter]
uh where we will do watch alongs I think
we might do one next week for the
um
the uh Lord of the Rings on September
2nd the Rings and power the first two
rings of power yeah
um but uh I don't know we're gonna need
we're gonna need some experts because I
don't know do you guys know anything
about Lord of the Rings yeah I mean I
haven't read I haven't read the
simarillion or a lot of the extended
Universe stuff but I have read The
Hobbit in The Lord of the Rings and well
we'll need at least one person who knows
talking about so you might have I might
compare it
yeah and now I bet we could find
somebody let's check out some outtakes
what did we cut for
story
kid on the Block little yellow different
sponge blobs two milder Wheezy Rider
hustle and foe Universal Lobster a nun
to Chuck wit big Glides he Glides
Scott's tots
I would say best episode of The Office I
think Scott's time oh so good I think
that's my I think that's my number one
yeah it's a beautiful thing
um we have some really good questions so
let's get into this uh first up we were
discussing this but we couldn't find the
video Evan J pretzer says this movie got
a Fight Club style censored ending in
China wild Knuckles gets away at the end
of the movie but in China they were like
no he goes to jail he goes to jelly
served a sentence and he uh was released
and raised a family with three beautiful
daughters I think it's the full
description of very old so so we
couldn't find him if you can link us
something on like weibo or whatever we I
was going to put it in this video but we
could find it um and the fight club one
he's referring to is also like Tyler
Durden was apprehended for his crimes at
the they put that on the Chinese right
away with that stuff Bringing Down the
financial system come on yeah uh his
question is what movie would you give a
similar treatment to in the U.S if you
could
um like it doesn't actually end this way
yeah like just a poochie died on their
way back to their home planet style I
see oh I would it would be great to just
put like on on the gray man like and
then he disappeared and never did
another spy mission again don't worry
don't worry don't worry Ryan got a
permanent retirement not interested in
being a gray man anymore and not the
whole program down and that child's
heart is fine
wrap it off it really works with any uh
like crime movie and not another red
notice was ever sent again right uh
uh text Scrolls up like they all were
arrested after this yeah especially uh
the acrobatic guy that went back to
China
yeah uh all right other questions
include
um
uh gym 1s completely off topic but are
there plans for a house of Dragon review
the first episode was surprisingly good
and would love to see if Spencer's back
on board or not
great question uh look I was holding out
hope that this would be terrible so that
I wouldn't have to talk about it because
when something's good and popular
um that means more work so uh we will do
something we're gonna probably get the
old gang back together
not next week but like I'm probably a
mid-season check-in
um and also
it could still totally fumble the bag in
episodes two and up but man I thought
the first episode was great uh I hate
that I that that's the case
um it kind of feels like it lacks a
little bit of the complexity like the
the pilot in the first few episodes of
Game of Thrones they're setting up so
much you learn so many characters so
many houses so many conflicts and this
one I feel like it's really just this
one but having said that I liked what I
yeah I want to see more I mean on name
complexity alone like 10 people are all
named vasanis and you have to tell all
the similar Targaryen looking people
apart right uh which is tough wow it's
tough It's uh because they're all
related which I can't scrub from my yeah
their family tree is a is a flat circle
yeah it really is a flat circle and
y'all you know yeah
and yes everybody you've already I've
gotten all of your very kind
um appreciative uh tweets yes they were
bad yeah if when you're born the gods
play the coin for madness
you might be Targaryen
housebox
[Laughter]
hang on to that bit that's a tournament
if your grandpa
hilarious you might be a Target
anymore well this will be this is a
little preview capture
I can I I can I just submit chasing the
dragon
title yeah I like it I mean watching
Thrones has some like history behind it
but I'm fine to do chasing the dragon
that's good I mean we're still we're
still watching Thrones so either is
viable can we can the theme song be
Steely Dan's time out of mind that's
what I was imagining record of course it
shouldn't it be like a uh unleash the
dragon unleash the dragon either either
way from what's his name the Thong Song
guy
can we get Cisco to co-host I think
that's the next question and can we have
him
Cisco on Cameo
Cisco speak minion we could do cameos of
his reaction to the house of the Dragon
yeah every week they'll say whatever you
ask
um he'll review it for us if we ask
there was one other Dragon thing it's
from Miami Connection the I think their
band was called oh yeah they're they're
yes you're right the band from the Mind
dragon sound yeah oh that's kind of a
bad we got a lot of options I mean look
they're a Taekwondo band so you gotta
have a dragon name right
if you're both a Taekwondo group in a
band uh let's see so here's let's talk
about Hitler um James bunt says the
minions conveniently were in a cave
during World War II rather than working
for the guy we always
Frozen during World War II you might be
my minion who do you think they would
work for today interesting question but
uh we made that observation in the
Minions One on his trailer and I think
somebody rightfully pointed out in uh
the comments that we would have wanted
the minions working for Hitler because
they're always sending their schemes
yeah awry right and he'd be like minions
yeah uh I think it's obviously Elon Musk
and I think that the minions are working
for him and that's right because that's
why his cars keeping like it's always
like this truck's window will never
break and then it shatters on stage like
these Teslas would never hit a child in
the road
that was Otto yeah um I mean Bezos might
be three minions
foreign
yeah I think it's really it's a I mean
you know like Trump is the other obvious
answer but no I I think it's a I think
it's a taxi yeah
um um let's see uh I think that's pretty
much it that's all I wanted to oh yeah
and people are asking us to weigh in on
uh uh Pericles dragon balls and
later oh Louisville that are asking us
about the HBO Max Purge imperging yeah
the growing uh cutting and consolidation
of everything that they're doing uh it
sucks uh for a whole bunch of reasons
there's really there's some good and bad
news about this stuff because a lot of
it is because of tax stuff basically
Warner Brothers Discovery gets to
consider itself a new company for this
one tax year so they can take a lot of
their assets and say we don't want these
assets or need them anymore and write
them off and what that means is they get
to write them off of their taxes but
then they can never make money on them
ever again so the good news is they
can't do this after this year this is
like a one-time thing it's not like HBO
every year is going to be like cut these
50 shows to save us money they can't do
it after this because Warner Brothers
Discovery isn't a new company anymore
the bad news is the stuff that we're
losing that they're cutting right now
basically legally they can't ever sell
again or make money on so like Infinity
train is just gone gone and until
another company acquires it as an asset
basically yeah yeah which is a real
shame and you really feel for the
creators of a lot of these great shows
that you know their work just sort of
disappears into this void for
potentially years or forever my only
hope is that this is something that is
written into the whenever the guild
Agreements are up of uh writersgill
Director's Guild produce Guild et cetera
that there are safeguards against this
happening yeah um again because that
girl's gone like they said that they
like as soon as they got word that it
was not going to go ahead they like went
to go see what they could like Salvage
off the servers and it was just all gone
wow so I mean there may be a copy that
exists somewhere I saw a lot of people
say like they deleted it off their
computer system like we don't know them
no that's probably probably for legal
reasons not all one computer they
probably have for legal reasons some
copies left over but but that's exact
that falls under the same rule because
God is this algorithms yes dot digital
Don Tito is doing all that well there is
to see at the end of that movie where
like they're deleting bugs buddy and
he's like digitally he's like that's
happening that's what's going on uh but
yeah so I I but it does this does mean
like they're never legally they can't
make money on Batgirl anymore so like
they can't put it on HBO Max next year
just to like if they change their mind
which sucks but they still own the
rights because it's not like we can make
a Batgirl movie there's snow no no no
because they own DC so so you couldn't
just put it on somewhere else it's like
it doesn't belong oh well uh it's the
world we live in that was minions too
next week is
um
let's see next week is something that uh
goes its own way doesn't follow the
rules
we love it for that don't we don't we
folks we we love a movie don't we folks
we love a movie folks we love the
minions they're little they're yeah
they're very helpful they fly a plane
that's that's always fun to watch have
you seen this have you seen the biggest
I'm flying a place
still they keep
them
Donald
is a 12 billion dollar a year industry
you gotta go
what would you say you do here
um all right thanks for watching we'll
be back next week bye-bye wait would you
say something Ryan no I was laughing oh
you're laughing great hey you'd love to
hear it all right bye-bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]